a knife of one's own and things taking
on a life of their own
a themes that connect the installations
by media artists Kilian Kretschmer
recently he's been experimenting a lot
with mirrors like and his work entitled
ass and it uses a [ __ ] two walls and
four mirrors his installations have been
shown in France Russia and Switzerland
among other countries
hallo ich bin achillion hi i'm kelly
anne from i've looked in Karlsruhe since
2005 and i loved this city because i can
really grow here as an artist I'm going
to show you three nice places let's go
Killians first tip takes us to castles
largest district Dula it was a city in
its own right until it was incorporated
in 1938 today Duloc has nearly 30,000
residents picturesque old lanes wind
through the center of this historic
district Dolokhov was once seat of the
margrave's of baden Duloc but the castle
burned down during the nine years war
and was only partially rebuilt this is
the center of door lock behind me is the
Carl's Board the castle in which Carl
Vilhelm designed the city of Karlsruhe
300 years ago the Margrave apparently
found that damaged castle too confining
do look has its own little mountain that
marks the start of the northern black
forest region it can be reached by a
cable car but there are still a few
steps to go to reach the viewing tower
the two and Becca's Tower Hill it's a
popular place for outings you get a
wonderful view over Karlsruhe and all
the way to France
and you can see the sight of the other
Schlacht HOF or old slaughterhouse
Killians next tip the abattoir closed
down in 2006 and the complex has been
turned into a Center for artists and
creative minds
it has spaces for Studios events and
exhibitions in one of the buildings
people rent containers as office space
they're mainly used by startup companies
a few buildings away is the Fitch Mercer
the former fat rendering plant it's now
a top party location here in the old
slaughterhouse complex my favorite place
to party is in the fetch melt so there's
always something going on
world-famous DJ's make this club the
place for music lovers from the old
slaughterhouse we move on to the
cultural palace more precisely to the
palace gardens the Botanical Garden is
here and historical buildings like the
owner Tony Kushner from the bustle of
the city the greenhouses were there
exotic plants are like a tiny paradise
Killians favorite spot in the large
palace park is the Fasano garden or
pheasant garden when the weather is fine
it's a popular destination for
barbecuing drinking and just meeting up
with friends lots of young people come
here for picnics in the Fasano garden
it's a great place to relax at the end
of the day I hope you've enjoyed my
little tour of Karlsruhe